así como en general puede dejar el
ejército para convertirse en una persona
común y corriente también las
circunferencias pueden transformar sus
ecuaciones de una en otra revisaremos
unos cuantos pasos para saber cómo
transformar una ecuación general en una
ecuación ordinaria para circunferencias
para eso buscaremos el centro y el radio
de la siguiente circunferencia con su
ecuación general
x cuadrada más cuadrada más 4 x + 4 y
menos 8 igual a 0
como primer paso debemos agrupar y
separar los términos de las variables x
y dejando un espacio porque vamos a
convertir esta expresión en 2 trinomios
cuadrados perfectos
ahora vamos a pasar el 8 del otro lado
porque no tiene ninguna incógnita y como
está restando pasa sumando y 0 + 8 son 8
como segundo paso podemos obtener el
trinomio cuadrado perfecto para
encontrarlo agruparemos los términos de
x
busquemos el término faltante para
formar los trinomios comencemos por la
ecuación del rectángulo azul donde está
x para encontrarlo tomaremos el 4 de x y
lo vamos a dividir entre 2 que es igual
a más 2 y elevado al cuadrado es más 4
este 4 lo colocamos en el espacio que
teníamos después de x cuadrada + 4x y
así ya tenemos nuestro primer binomio
cuadrado
hagamos lo mismo con la ecuación del
recuadro verde tomamos el 4 de iu y lo
dividimos entre 2 lo que es igual a 2 lo
elevamos al cuadrado y esto nos da como
resultado más 4 bien escribimos 4
después de 4 y así obtenemos nuestros 2
trinomios cuadrados perfectos
para continuar con el tercer paso vamos
a igualar nuestra ecuación eso lo
haremos agregando los dos cuadros que
incorporamos en nuestros trinomios al 8
que habíamos despejado desde el inicio
ahora resolvemos esta última operación
sumando 8 4 + 4 que nos da 16
como cuarto paso factor izamos cada
trinomio cuadrado perfecto para
factorizar tomas del primer y último
término y como están elevados al
cuadrado sacaremos la raíz cuadrada de
cada uno de ellos y eso es un 2
y así de fácil fue transformar una
ecuación general en una ecuación
ordinaria siguiendo solamente cuatro
pasos recuerda
uno agrupa términos y variables dos
buscas trinomios cuadrados perfectos
tres igual las ecuaciones y cuatro
factorías finalmente sabemos que el
centro de este círculo es 2,2 y el radio
es igual a 4 porque es la raíz cuadrada
de 16 cómo observás te transformar una
ecuación general a ordinaria no es
complicado sólo tienes que seguir los
pasos anteriores y seguir practicando